With over 30 million albums sold, 80 million song downloads...
...and seven Grammys to her name, Taylor Swift is anything but average,...
...but let's just see how she compares to the regular girl.
At five feet ten inches tall, Taylor is a full six inches taller...
...than the adult US female average of 5'4...
...and weighs 45 pounds less,...
...putting her closer to the average runway model than the average US woman.
Taylor Swift goes on too many dates, or at least that's what people say.
With seven confirmed boyfriends, she has had 3.5 times...
...as many boyfriends as the average woman,...
...who has only had two long-term relationships in her life.
With a net worth of 200 million dollars,...
...Taylor has appeared on the list of Forbes' richest celebrities five times...
...and is a full 23,474 times as wealthy as the average person in the United States...
...who has a net worth of 8,525 dollars.